[Music]
tori is in cleveland ohio starting off
this hour hi tori how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so i am kind of in just like a pickle
of what to do
i've been listening to you for a little
bit now and i've worked really hard
the last like two months to just get
that paid down i originally was
living with someone in an apartment and
i ended up moving back
home and fortunately event however um
it's a really like
toxic place to live in and so i'm like
basically seeming to get out
and i i just kind of don't know what to
do because of
like going through bills like i have the
every dollar app and like when i look
through it it's
very much so that i either would live
like pennies in the dollars or i'd be
over
so i just don't know how to go about
this
tori why do you say it's toxic i'm
curious
um like i mean
it is meant like messing up with my
mental health
and so like it makes things almost worse
because i'm like
i'm like i just hate it like it's like
every day like a problem i
i'm one of five kids and the three
younger kids have disabilities
um so and my parents
just you know definitely struggled to
handle it and
it's a mixture of disabilities of mental
and behavioral issues
so uh just even a quick example like
if i'm sleeping and i need to wake up at
like
eight or eight o'clock because that's
what time i want to wake up i'll
probably wake up around seven to
my father screaming at the kids
and that's just like i mean barely even
a tiptoe dive into like
like what it's like so how old how old
are you
23. and i think i heard you say you
don't make enough to live on your own
feel like i don't make enough no it's
not a feeling it's it's a math thing
yeah how much do you have
i my base uh pay is 35 000
a year i make a little bit of commission
each month
on a conservative end my monthly income
is right around
200 and or 2 200 you make enough to live
on your own
you sure do okay
i don't know what all you're trying to
put in the every dollar app what all
you're trying to finance here have you
got a bunch of debt
33 000 in debt it's a mixture of
um in auto loans for 13 000 that is
under someone else
someone else's name but i'm a co-signer
and i've been trying to
figure that out for a while and i just
pretty much the gentleman's not letting
me do anything with it
then i have a personal my personal loan
like are you driving the car
or is he i'm driving the car okay so you
need to treat it like it's your car loan
and get it paid off and get your car
right yeah yeah so i've been doing some
i've been doing that very much so yes
good um and then i have 15 000 in
student loans
and i just went from six thousand
dollars in credit card debt
to 2000. yeah what do you do
um i work at verizon okay 40 hours
i actually i'm like i'm on i'm like
actually at verizon right now
do you work 40 hours i do work 40 hours
yes and i've been looking at a part-time
job
okay yeah you need one you knew you do
yeah yeah or two
or three stop looking good anything else
to do
yeah you have any kids tori
no i don't have any kids okay all right
so uh yeah you do need to get out and
you may just need to get a good roommate
and find out you'll find yourself in a
an apartment situation that's very very
affordable no you can't afford something
super expensive you don't make a lot of
money
but if you got a rent if your rent was
five six hundred bucks your part
um which is very doable in cleveland
ohio
uh if you had a roommate for sure you
can do this
or find just a little studio somewhere
in the you know garage apartment out
back of some old lady's house type of a
thing
uh it doesn't need to be anything fancy
it just needs to be quiet and yours
yeah yeah my um my monthly payment on my
car is 443 dollars a month and it'll be
paid off in less than three years
your your car is going to be paid off a
lot faster than that because you're
gonna get six jobs and you're gonna pay
off all of this really fast
i want you to double your income yeah
okay but all you're gonna be doing is
working for a little while because right
now here's what you've got here's what
you got okay
you may you don't make enough money to
not be miserable
with the debt and the living situation
so the way to fix the debt and the
living situation
is more money to fix both of them
does that make sense yeah and if you fix
both of those
if you had no debt and you could make a
budget that
that you could live in a decent
apartment uh
you'd have a really good life right now
at 23 years old and you'd be on your way
choosing what career you wanted to do
and all that kind of thing right
yeah yeah yeah so i want you to get like
six jobs i want you to be a nanny
i want you to be dog sitting i want you
to be i don't care
whatever it is you like to do but let's
go make up some money
absolutely i mean you can make two
thousand dollars a month just
you know delivering pizzas on a week you
know five days a week at night
yeah yeah and depending on what your
education is i want you to go to
tutor.com
start tutoring some kids they're paying
right around 75 to 150
an hour depending on what you could
bring to the table
and if you could do that from home a few
nights an hour uh
i mean not a few nights but a few hours
a night i mean you could really make it
so there are some things out there that
you can do to generate some extra income
to go towards paying off your debt and
getting your income higher yeah but
here's the first thing the first thing
is you lay out a budget that takes care
of food
utilities shelter and car payment yeah
and minimum payments on the credit cards
and call the student loan as
in as a hardship deferral if you have to
and then you go get six jobs
and you start plowing through your debt
snowball listing your debts smallest to
largest
i'm telling you if you go make another
thirty thousand dollars next year
on top of what you already make you
could be 100
debt free in one year and that's going
to change your whole position of where
you are
you can actually do this but your
brain's kind of foggy
because you're just kind of stuck in
this uh job that's not like your big
career job that you really wanted you've
got this situation back at the house
that you're trying to get away from
and uh and it's hard to just do simple
math when you're when your brain's
working like this
so we're telling you we're looking at it
and i think you can lay out a simple
budget
that just says food utilities
roommate rent and uh pay the car payment
keep gas in the car and work all the
time
no life you're not gonna get to go out
running around you don't get to go out
to eat you don't get to go to bars on
the weekend you're gonna be working
unless you're working at one of them
that's the only place you're gonna be
that's one place
you're gonna see the inside of a
restaurant or a bar okay so it's time to
get game on
and go catgo take your life by the
throat
and shake it and make it behave
absolutely